c'est la riposte que tout le monde
attendait en début d'après-midi à
washington joe biden a indiqué qu'il
n'était pas du les agissements de l'adie
mire poutine
que pour lui la reconnaissance des
régions séparatistes de données ce qui
est de l'ouest par moscou signifiait le
début d'une invasion russe en ukraine
non
malgré l'escaladé ou baden répète qu'il
n'a nullement l'intention d'envoyer des
troupes sur le terrain
il annonce tout de même des sanctions
entre autres compte des institutions
financières et des élites russes
quelques heures plus tard à ottawa
justin trudeau annonce des mesures
similaires et on va imposer des
sanctions supplémentaires contre les
banques russes soutenu par l'état et
interdire toute transaction financière
avec elle le gouvernement trudeau
enverra aussi plus de militaires dans la
région en lettonie pour renforcer son
appui à l'otan et ce n'est qu'un début
dit mélanie joly l'invasion a commencé
nous répondons donc aujourd'hui plus la
russie intensifie ses agressions plus
les actions du canada et de nos alliés
vont s'intensifier
le gouvernement fédéral un pleur
d'ailleurs ses ressortissants qui se
trouvent encore en ukraine de rentrer au
pays absolument je
rappelle que n'entend pas écouté lydia
walenski une canadienne installée dans
l'ouest de l'état depuis trente ans je
peux le désir
de évacuer l'ukraine maintenant je sans
danger direct
jjb
l'espoir que les grands pays comme le
vol des sobriquets les canadiennes où on
réagira c'est effectivement et cet
expert en sécurité internationales doute
que les sanctions économiques imposées
jusqu'à maintenant on freine l'ardeur de
vladimir poutine que les sanctions ne
sont pas tendus pour prévenir les
comportements à risque pour le punir
et puis occidentaux ont promis
d'ailleurs de punir davantage la russie
moscou intensifie son offensive
la voie diplomatique reste ouverte
répète les états unis même si elle
semble de plus en plus fermé ici
laurence martin radio canada